hello and welcome to part 7 of my SEO
tutorial series this tutorial is going
to be covering the idea of content and
SEO of your page now until this point
we've really been only covering more
like formality type of stuff and it's
time to so you graduate from that and
move into a bit of a harder part and
that's gonna be content now in the
future we'll also graduate to an even
harder part and that's going to be the
structure and functionality of your your
website which sometimes you'll never be
able to get perfect but it's kind of
like a constant battle so anyway on to
content historically people used to just
kind of load up their pages with various
keywords and that actually actually
worked even if the sentence has made no
logical sense right but like I was
explaining before that's not good for
Google and they're gonna constantly be
working away from that so and really now
we're at the point where that it does
not work for you it actually will hinder
you which we'll talk about in a little
bit now even if you make logical sense
still loading up with keywords is
actually against your best interest and
it's kind of like what we're talking
about having too many ads on your page
when we were debunking the idea that if
you pay for a tour yeah if you have
Adsense that maybe they might rank you
better since they make money on you and
it's really not the case that you're
actually hurt by this and so I know with
keywords even if let's say you have a
single keyword if you just keep using
that you just keep your name dropping
that keyword that's actually gonna hurt
you because it will look like it would
be spammy right and if a regular person
was reading that they would be like look
this makes no sense it's kind of a weird
sound so with keywords how much is too
much
generally you want to think of it as
like a ratio or a percentage so you
wouldn't want to be like don't say it
more than five times well if you use
5,000 words on a page obviously you can
use it more than five five times now I
don't recommend using 5,000 words on a
page but anyway generally you can use
five percent as a loose rule so so
basically
whatever keyword you want to use you
want to make sure that it doesn't exceed
5% of that pages total word content so
if one iteration of that keyword exceeds
5 percent of the total page then you
probably don't even have enough content
and you probably shouldn't focus too
much on that specific page obviously
you're gonna want to have sentences make
logical sense to you know that helps
along those lines a recognizable font
type and a reasonable size is also
judged so you wouldn't want to go like
two absurdly large or two absurdly small
interestingly enough it seems to be the
font size of about 11 is suggested now I
I think I would prefer if every website
had more like at 12 or 13 or something
but 11 is typically what suggested and
you want to go with a font that's easy
to read and then also the spacing
between lines should be relatively
larger than you might expect
so anyway what it always depends on the
font and then also if you view it on
various browsers you'll see that it
looks a little bit different and so it
is important that you view it on
multiple types of browsers just so you
can see well what does every user
looking at right but well we'll get in
more into that with the structure and
functionality later but you just kind of
keep that in mind the next thing to
think about when it comes to readability
besides what we were about to get into a
structure and functionality is your
sentence structure
I guess that's structure but not really
its content it's what I'm trying to get
at your sentence structure should be as
basic as possible because it makes it
easier for the reader to read it so you
know it's not like your readers are
idiots right but it is just easier to
read simple sentences that aren't and
you always want to like reference you
shouldn't use you know pronouns it's
always good to go ahead and reference
whatever you're talking about you know
want to be absolutely clear with what
you're saying because it makes it easier
to read same thing you wouldn't want to
use very large words again it's not not
because your readers might be idiots
it's just that it makes it easier to
read and so really that's all that's
that's about Google knows this and
actually do look for sentence structure
the types of words that you're using as
far as how easily will this actually be
read and also they will look at your
your fonts and all this kind of stuff so
just as a warning sometimes Google is
gonna flag a word is misspelled as well
so obviously you want to spell
everything right although if you don't
that's gonna hurt you why sometimes I
found words I wish I could think of a
good word right now that I've found that
Google says spelled wrong you know it
gives you that little squiggly line in
Google Chrome and it tells you that word
spelled wrong even though it's spelled
right I would highly suggest you just
change the word right it's I'm not
positive on it but but I'm guessing they
use probably the same spell checker and
so on some of these words that your live
one that's the word you know just
changed the word because it could
possibly bring you down I'm pretty sure
it does so so because I do know
misspelled words do so when Google says
you spelled something wrong just just
change it and sometimes you can like
submit the word so it's not you know do
your part and submit the word but still
change it so keywords 5% of the total
volume you know per keyword on each page
basically that said I wouldn't really
try to focus on more than one key word
or a key phrase per page also when it
comes to keywords it's generally
suggested that you only focus on on one
page with one key word so that might
sound like exactly what I just said but
but really like say your see you uh so
you get a good rank one of your pages
for dog cookies it wouldn't make much
sense for you to make another page and
really focus on dog cookie right because
you would in a sense be competing
against yourself right you only need one
page to be in a high ranked you could
have multiple pages but it's really in
your best interest to let that happen
naturally but target other keywords as
well so instead of dog cookie you could
use dog treats or something like that
right so when it comes to keywords
only more than 5% on the page but also
really you know focus on one keyword on
each page also no matter how tedious it
might be along the lines of keyword and
stuff you want to always have titles and
alts tags or every single image that you
have and because images alone are almost
worthless and I say almost because it's
actually good to have an image on a page
it does actually add flavor but it helps
even more to describe that image and you
get a lot more out of it one thing I
think a lot of people might be
forgetting is some of your organic
results can actually come from image
searches and and your image can actually
become a good source of traffic if
you've got a good image that matches
your title and alt tags for it
so let me just let's bring up let's look
up this article here like what can
blackberry do differently so we click on
this article here and and actually while
we're here as well you want to keep this
in mind also for for what's called
anchor text so on all of your URLs
instead of putting like if I hover this
you should see the URL that it goes to
goes of blackberry com let's press
blackberry calm slash price oh well
anyway it's the article but if you just
like slapped that in there with just
that link it's not very descriptive but
instead now the keywords is BlackBerry's
letter of intent to go to Fairfax
Financial at nine dollars a share and if
you you can also give it title tags as
well I don't think it's as important but
if you did if you did and you hovered
this it would give you a title of that
so for example let's go to the UK
sentiment or just click on one here and
you'll see that if I hover over this
there's there's a the title tag of
capita sentiment right and obviously so
sentiment I'm using that you know to my
best interest and then anyway back here
I guess we've shown you on that one but
let's view the source of this page we'll
scroll down to
where the article is I suspect here we
go
so again if you're not familiar with
making links obviously like this is this
is that that single link that we were
just showing you so a href equals the
actual link and then you know close the
quotes and then whatever goes in here is
just what the link will say and so it
could say anything but a lot of times
people just put the link like right in
there or like the word press will just
do that automatically for you instead
you should describe it like this the
next thing I wanted to show you is with
alt tags now this is a little bit a
little bit different because it's
WordPress but anyway here's the image
and you can see it ends basically here
and well they've made it into a link in
an image that's that's the problem
anyway
normally this would you know image class
equals blah blah blah and then this is
like the alternative text to that image
and so a good example of why the
alternative text could be beneficial to
you in my case let me open up and do a
google search sometimes images are
actually included in the main search and
also obviously in the image search but
say for example someone was to type in
obama sentiment you know there's some of
this like actual text here but then you
come down here and there's actual images
here for obama sentiment well it just so
happens that this is actually one of my
images right this is actually from sent
XCOM and so that's an example of why
images can even help just straight up in
the search results but then also
obviously if you went to the images you
would see that we also obviously occupy
image number one even before you know
political twitter and all this stuff so
pretty cool and it can be very
beneficial to your organic traffic
so let's gonna conclude this tutorial
for content obviously there's a still a
lot more to talk about with content we
might go even more in depth with content
later but mostly you just want to you
know don't go overboard on the keywords
you know don't be silly about it be you
know just type the way you would
normally type um
don't don't be too complex in your
sentence structure try to keep it as
simple as possible make sure you
describe and use you know descriptive
anchor anchor text for every link that's
in your page and you do want to have
links it does help whether they're
internal or you know linking out and
obviously you know make sure that you
give descriptive text alt text and title
text to all of your images and those
three things can make a huge difference
for your website and it because it gives
Google and Bing way more information on
what that page actually is cuz you got
to understand you got to think of it as
if you were a crawl bot and you're
looking you know because they're
basically seeing they're basically
seeing the source code and so if your
image is like forty four three nine two
PNG that doesn't tell them anything that
doesn't mean anything to them
so anyway keep that in mind and good
luck with your SEO in the next video
we'll be talking a little bit about
functionality and structures with your
website as always thanks for watching
thanks for your support your
subscriptions and until next time